all right clive
welcome back thank you welcome back so
there's been some developments in your
story since since you were here last
refresh my viewers stories because i
posted your first video months ago
just give us like a paragraph or two of
of your story
thanks mom
i was here a few months ago and uh you
know uh
talking about my homelessness and um
i'm back today to kind of refresh
those people who already seen the video
and now also to
tell
a lot of people wanted to support you
you're the people yeah
that uh
are supporting me i all would like to
support me yeah they're um a few people
that i met tonight well before before
you get into who's helping you
let's just do a recap of your story you
lost your son tragically uh yes uh last
time i was here i um
you know i i talked about
the loss of my son
and that um
you know uh the loss of my business
you you were in the restaurant business
yes i was in the restaurant
at a restaurant right yes our restaurant
brownstone bistro located in the
mid-city
i lost my restaurant after
nine
11 years
and um uh after your son was dead of my
son you know
my divorce came through about the same
time as as everything else and um it
left me homeless and um
being homeless is one of the hardest
things that i've encountered
you know uh
trying to survive
uh um
my experience being homeless um
was terrible i slept on
some tents i opened my eyes there's some
big rats that i've never seen
in my lifetime and that's those rats you
you try to get
it's fun to move they stand they're
looking at you they chase you he had
they ready to fight you yes and um you
know he was very scary you know i lost a
lot of things my
personal things my
you know i bought two bags in a week it
was stolen right in front of my eyes let
me even see
i don't know see how that happened but
things like that happen
you know
i try hard to get away from
this kind of life uh because i'm not
used to this at all
so now there's some people in my life
who are
helping me or intend to help me uh at
the moment i'm in a motel uh uh been
financed by uh one of the angels that
called these people uh um
and uh there are others who
who uh take me around to
get my hair cut and you know um would
purchase clothes for me and so again
i gotta be thankful because
things is looking better
since the last time i was here
and um and you started or someone helped
you started gofundme yes there was an
angel who who actually
put a gofundme page together
and it was already together before she i
met her
yes and that was i never thought knowing
that would happen
but uh so you have a bank account tied
to it and all that yes yes so you know
we get that together and the bank
account is
tied together and i'll put a link to it
in the description of this video
as well as your other video okay first
one
yeah and where are you at today
i'm in in actually i'm i'm in mid city
yeah at the motel
now what are your what are your hopes
and plans here my hope and plans moving
forward is
i love to get a food truck a catering
truck
and um
this is all connected to what i do best
i'm a chef by trade and um
i am
my main objective too because that
catering truck is to
come back and help some of these
homeless people who
would like to move forward
uh um
also
all along i love to
work with young upcoming chefs
to try to happen to get uh
get their focus on some
something positive you know in their
life
that's great
and so you still have other family
that's still around you have kids yes uh
three kids uh
my first mom who who passed and um
uh my second my second son was at howard
university
and you know he's majoring in civil
engineering and then my daughter who
just graduated from
uh uh
from
school here he was at she was accepted
in southern university she's the med
student
your daughter yes she wouldn't be a
doctor
all right exactly
those uh my kids they they make me proud
and even i must say my son who passed
he left
a good
uh some good footprints for upcoming
kids because
again the my son was the poster boy
against gang balance my son was never in
the gang
but of course he became the poster boy
against gang warlings
the city the police department and the
churches
took my son as their own and
make sure the world understand that
my son was my gang member he did a lot
of good
for gang gangs yeah the gangs are out of
control
he is
passing away after his death
you know
my son was
still was talked about
that's great so
you have some people that are helping
you and uh that's got to be very
encouraging i mean to go from being
homeless and losing most things in your
life including your son
to having some people that are coming
out of the woodwork just to kind of help
you get your last your life together is
it's a beautiful thing right yes be very
beautiful and like you know explain to
all the people i've met so far and
helping me
i
i just said
call my angel because
these people just
saw me and like
one guy said to me i just hear his story
and i told him my story and um
it was so amazing he said i'll be back
but i never think i would ever see this
guy anymore
and um
you know he um he was back in about 45
minutes
and he was i was standing in the middle
of the street you know
trying to collect some money for food
and for housing if i could
and he said uh
after he came back he said
let's talk
he took me over to the side of the
street we were parking and he went in
his pocket
i said this is for you this is for your
next few night hotels it was like 400
dollars i was like
i never i never think that would ever
happen
i and the guy told me the next day for a
haircut
he told me to eat
i'll keep telling
he said pick what they want from the
stores
and whatever clothes i said i cannot buy
i don't want nobody to give me all this
toast there's nowhere to put these laws
people couldn't steal them he said at
least get four pairs of everything
i'm in the store and
this guy like i said it's too much money
he said don't worry about it jesus paid
for these already i was like so he said
amazing and this guy's
back and forth making sure that i'm okay
he tend to eat you know he's a producer
he went to another uh
state and he got sick
convenient
yeah and what happened so he's still in
the recovery right now oh okay so he
didn't pass away he's just said no no
yeah but
you know i was like yeah i felt it from
my heart like wow
you know
yeah there are people out there that
have good hearts
but you're you know having said that
i'll say that
not everyone i interview on my channel
has the potential to do what you're
doing you know you you came from a
successful life you were on the gordon
ramsay show right yes and you you you
you have a pedigree you've been trained
you're very talented
um
and and so you know what is required to
build a business and make it successful
you just kind of got lost with
the murder of your son
yeah and divorce can break the diet
yeah the kneecaps and a lot of things
that just kind of took you down but
i believe like
a couple other people i've interviewed
that you have the potential to do
everything you can to
to get your life straight again yes so
it's easy to help someone like you
because
that we can imagine you having
everything you dream about
very easily whereas some of the drug
addicts they'll tell me one thing and do
another and then it's just hard to move
forward with helping them
and you and you can accept it too
because yeah so that's a big part of it
also is is having the interviewee
you know accept the help that he's been
given
and so far
i must say i'm blessed and i've been
thankful because
you know uh for the past
few
weeks uh
two of the angels
put me to stay in the motel
and you know i i'm feeling bad because
you're paying so much money to just
accommodate me you know i'm going to
tell but i'm like wow
you know
but i must say that
i must say thank you to all those people
who are
who are supportive of me and
you know i i
i i crave the help and i need the help
well your story was heartbreaking and
it's
it's satisfying for people like myself
or people that have come out of the
woodwork to help you
to be able to do something for you
because
to see somebody like you
just
living on the street
is
it's just difficult and i must say mark
that um
the experience on the street
i'm thankful for that experience but
it's kind of hard for me because again
this experience i will
and i
continued to share it
with people because they would not
understand they would not even
understand what happened on the streets
it's so dangerous and so these people
have a mind of their own yeah i was like
wow
they care about
nothing
nothing
and i'm like
i said to one guy
you know because they
in
ten
somebody got hurt and
they were about to burn the tents down
and i told another guy who next door i
said you know i'm gonna stay here to
make sure that everything is safe he
said don't worry about it
i don't care i was like
guys lives next door you gotta talk
about that you don't hear them those
things don't hurt me like
they don't care if you you're dying
they're not gonna help you yeah so i
can't be around this no because that
close my eyes
sometimes
sometimes things are just not
not fixable
but it's nice to see you trying to climb
out yes
and we'd love to help you out thank you
so uh there'll be a link in the go fund
me i'll put in the description of this
video as well as your first video and
i'll
maybe i'll repost the first video or
something just to refresh everyone's
memory of your story
and i wish you
lots of luck with your food talk
thank you and your future you deserve it
man thank you i'm ready to take on the
world awesome thank you chris thank you
god